et est ce que c'est un vrai coup l'heure
où tu refais d'un tout petit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma vraie couleur car j'ai pu voir
avec mathieu quel point une couleur de
cheveux pouvait foiré
[Applaudissements]
en revanche narnia un truc rigolo c'est
une fois blanchi à dégorger s'est passé
votre vie personnelle
begin a mon avis tu fais tu venais pour
un tout petit latéraux n'ont en revanche
c'est vrai que j'ai des cheveux chelou
dans la carte au trésor parce que je
suis au dessus d'un pare soleil vert
dont la cote est un pas vers un peu
bizarre voilà oui oui oui une question
comme un serment que c'est du spray
claire 600 mhz et répondez quoi je parle
j'ai dit la vérité je veux un truc salé
quoi éclaircissants c'est vrai c'est pas
grave j'ai trahi chez jean-claude salsa
rien sur va bien